bonjour hubert julien laferrière merci
beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation sur rt france alors on l'a vu
la situation sanitaire qui se détériore
en france le chef de l'état se laisse
huit à dix jours pour y voir plus clair
est-ce qu'il faut maintenir le cap et
essayer au maximum de vivre normalement
et possiblement de desserrer les mesures
barrières les mesures de restriction du
je crois que justement le prix dans la
rue qui gouvernement ont fait un pari et
quelques semaines alors que beaucoup de
scientifiques disaient il faut re
confiné où fait le pari de qui vont de
ce que le plateau de ne continue pas un
couteau se stabilisent voire avoir
baisse n'est pas critique à faire à ce
niveau là parce que c'est évidemment
compliqué d'être d'être aux affaires
dans cette situation sanitaire
il semble que maintenant on soit
vraiment dans une difficulté
moi ce que je demande au gouvernement
c'est de travailler davantage avec les
collectivités locales
parce que tout ne doit pas venir duo est
ici doit y avoir des recours finement
locaux il faut évidemment les envisager
avec les exécutifs des régions et les
villes on va le voir évidemment avec cet
exemple de nice mais auparavant la haye
la zone a fait sa rentrée aujourd'hui le
gouvernement avait annoncé le 10 février
dernier une campagne de dépistage massif
grâce au test salivaire écoutez olivier
ferrand et on en parle après le public
prioritaire ce sont les enfants dans nos
écoles de manière à pouvoir identifier
sans désagrément pour les enfants des
cas positifs et donc protéger et
préserver l'école dont nous souhaitons
qu'elle puisse rester ouverte le plus
longtemps possible
il y aura déjà des premiers tests
salivaires à partir de demain menés par
les hôpitaux de paris et dès la mi
février
nous emmènerons 200 à 300 milles par
semaine à deux cent à trois cent mille
tests salivaires par semaine jean castex
à elle a confirmé il a parlé de 50000 à
80 mille tests réalisés à cette semaine
tout cela pour maintenir les écoles
ouvertes à tout prix vous êtes vous-même
professeur est ce que c'est la bonne
solution selon vous moi je pense qu'il
faut effectivement une stratégie de
dépistage dommage
on a évidemment on a trop expliquer aux
parents et donc aux enfants que les que
les enfants n'étaient pas vecteur de
contamination
bon on se rend compte aujourd'hui qu'il
ne développe enfin pour la plupart la
maladie mais qu'ils sont vecteurs de
contamination et je crois qu'il faut une
stratégie globale de sensibilisation et
de dépistage
il ya eu une confusion parce que en fait
les 200 ou 300 mille tests salivaires
annoncé c'était pas que pour les enfants
et donc on se rend bien compte
aujourd'hui à la rentrée pour ce qui
concerne la zone à qui notamment à lyon
chez moi on n'a pas effectivement les
moyens de faire les l'ensemble des tests
salivaires
moi je vais pas jeter la pierre si si si
c'est comme pour les vaccins on n'a pas
assez de doses je me dis que c'est pas
que la faute du gouvernement mais en
tout cas cette souris c'est une
stratégie globale de tester
effectivement celle qu'il faut pouvoir
développer le plus rapidement possible
ouais alors en attendant c'est vrai que
les résultats m au moins 24 heures comme
les tests pcr
ça va être ça va être efficace selon vos
nerfs au moins toute façon pour la
rentrée on sait bien que la csi la
rentrée aujourd'hui donc efficace ou
n'aura pas les résultats pour la rentrée
puisqu'elle a commencé je vois sur
l'étiquette que je suis a marqué député
e élevé je suis pas du tout mais
génération écologie
je crois qu'à me précisait même si
effectivement d'ailleurs on l'a annoncé
comme ça c'est une erreur de script en
rond on s'en excuse puisqu'il doit le
bandeau au bas ou donc oui effectivement
jugé jeudi entre encore une fois c'est
évidemment la bonne stratégie
mais il faut certains pays d'europe 1
ont décidé de fermer les écoles
justement oui alors c'est évidemment pas
la stratégie du gouvernement parce que
le problème de la fermeture des écoles
bourse il faut en venir là parce que
parce qu'on ne maîtrise plus l'épidémie
il faudra en venir là mais problème des
fermetures de l'école on voit très bien
les difficultés que ça pose des
difficultés sociales ce sont les laits
évidemment les parents les plus en
difficulté les mères célibataires qui
évidemment ne peuvent plus aller
travailler et donc on voit bien les
défis qui s'imposent sur le terrain mais
s'il faut en venir à sète à cette
décision ultime
mais je crois que c'est vraiment la
dernière décision qu'il faut prendre
avant avant tout les autres alors vous
êtes l'un des rares députés à avoir
quitté la république en large pour
rejoindre justement les écologistes la
mairie de lyon va mettre en place des
menus végétariens partir d'aujourd'hui
pour lutter contre le virus c'est une
mesure qui suscite déjà la polémique
voyez ce qu'on a dit gérald darmanin
ministre de l'intérieur et on en parle
après en plus de l'insultent
inacceptable aux agriculteurs et aux
bouchers français on voit bien que la
politique moraliste et élitiste des
verts exclus les classes populaires
de nombreux enfants n'ont souvent que la
cantine pour manger de la viande
idéologie scandaleuse est ce que ça vous
paraît cohérent ses menus végétariens à
lyon alors écoutez là il ya vraiment une
polémique qui n'a pas lieu d'être mais
je suis assez assez je dirais scandalisé
par la façon dont on essaye tout temps
de décridibiliser les écologistes est
déjà entre les deux tours des
municipales quand la majorité a vu que
les écologistes avaient gagné de
nombreuses villes on les a caricaturés
en disant qu'ils allaient faire fuir
toutes les entreprises s'étaient c'était
franchement ridicule aujourd'hui les
maires écologistes aux affaires ils
gèrent bien leur ville et cette
polémique est ridicule parce que d'abord
c'est pour répondre effectivement au
protocole sanitaire demandé par le
gouvernement
il faut un âne sanitaire concrètement en
quoi ça répond protocole sanitaire
ça va très vite comme il faut une
distanciation il faut un menu unique
ça permet également d'accélérer service
et permettre d'accueillir tous les
enfants dans de bonnes conditions mais
rappelons-nous surtout
que gérard collomb ancien ministre de
l'intérieur maire de lyon avait pris
exactement la même décision il y a un an
et que ça n'avait pas du tout et vuli
géré alterman un mini le ministre de
normandie et là comme par hasard parce
que ce sont des écologistes qui prennent
la décision
eh bien ça émeut tout le monde non
cotées il ya un protocole sanitaire ce
sont des mesures qui sont raisonnables
c'est évidemment on a encore caricaturer
c'est pas des menus vais gagner il ya
des yeux il ya du poisson c'est juste un
menu sans viande le temps le temps
d'effectivement de retrouver une
situation plus normale on pourra avoir
des menus différents dans les
restaurants de scolaires de la ville
mais encore une fois je ne comprends pas
très bien cette polémique quand on sait
que que l'ancien ami de l'intérieur qui
était redevenu maire de lyon avait pris
exactement la même mesure il ya un nom
ça mais ça met en colère en tout cas les
les agriculteurs qui ont décidé de
manifester ce qu'il faut il faut pas
salir
l'idée de réduire un petit peu ça c'est
un autre sujet mais il ya des de réduire
un petit peu la consommation de viande
dans les cantines scolaires
c'est pas forcément une mauvaise y met
mauvaise idée parce que niveau mieux se
fournir localement avec le boucher local
avec les agriculteurs locaux et manger
moins de viande que manger de la viande
bon marché industriel tous les jours
c'est à la fois une question
environnementale est essentielle mais
les questions de préservation de notre
biodiversité et puis une question tout
simplement de soutien aux éleveurs
responsable aux éleveurs locaux
donc ça c'est évidemment un autre sujet
il n'y a pas de raison que ça met en
colère les agriculteurs en hausse et
c'est compliqué quand on est un maire de
pouvoir prendre des décisions qui
permettent de respecter des protocoles
sanitaires de d'éviter les
contaminations la propagation du virus
et c'est une mesure encore une fois
qu'ils avaient été prises par l'ancien
maire de lyon de la majorité si cette
mesure est reprise à nouveau par le
maire écologie servat semblablement quel
est son efficacité avons parié de prise
de décisions en concertation avec les
élus locaux notamment à nice le taux
d'incidence on l'a vu et trois fois et
demi supérieur à la moyenne nationale
est le préfet va annoncer des mesures
territorialise
à la mi journée c'est la première fois
que de telles mesures au niveau local
sont prises est ce que vous dites bravo
beaucoup de maires en tout cas le
réclamaient depuis longtemps toute
chasse aux gens courageux au maximum la
coopération entre l'exécutif les préfets
et puis les élus locaux pour prendre les
mesures adéquates sur le terrain on voit
bien que dans les alpes maritimes
il ya une situation particulièrement
difficile et donc bien je ne suis pas là
pour juger exactement de ce qui se
passait donc de ce qu'il faut faire à
nice mais en tout cas
évidemment il faut que des solutions
concertées entre le pouvoir national et
les locaux soit prise de manière
harmonieuse
allez on va parler de du projet de loi
relatif à la sécurité globale qui va
être examiné au sénat à partir du 3 mars
prochain
dominique estrosi sassone la sénatrice
les républicains des alpes-maritimes
elle préconise l'expulsion des
locataires dont les enfants seraient
condamnées pour trafic de drogue
cela pour lutter notamment contre les
troubles du voisinage
voyez comment ils le justifient et puis
on en parle après le trafic de drogue
est l'une des causes majeures des
troubles de voisinage dans les quartiers
cela constitue pour les locataires une
atteinte intolérable à la jouissance
paisible de leur logement
face au trafic de drogue les bailleurs
sociaux sont dépourvues d'outils adaptés
leur permettant d'y répondre
efficacement et rapidement
cela engendre une incompréhension des
voisins qui respecte les droits et les
devoirs
est ce une bonne mesure de ne plus
octroyer de logements sociaux aux
familles dont les enfants seraient
condamnées pour trafic de drogue et j'ai
été maire mois pendant huit ans- du 9e
arrondissement de lyon dont lequel il y
avait il ya toujours effectivement 22.22
deux endroits où il ya où il ya
régulièrement des trafics
c'est évidemment quelque chose qui
empoisonnent la vie la vie de nos
concitoyens
mais vous savez cette solution de
supprimer les allocations logement
c'est une vieille rengaine de la droite
et ça ne marche pas parce que moi je
connais à la fois les problèmes
effectivement que qui que pose le trafic
de drogue pour le voisinage
je connais aussi les problèmes de ces
familles souvent des familles
monoparentales qui ont des jeunes qui
effectivement ne se comporte pas comme
il faudrait dans le quartier mais c'est
ses parents sont souvent démunis alors
leur supprimer les allocations les
allocations logement ou les allocations
familiales
évidemment la dernière chose à faire
parce que c'est c'est une punition
collective c'est la double peine et je
crois qu'il faut plutôt faire ce que ce
qui n'est pas fait aujourd'hui renforcée
tout ce qui est soutien à l'éducation
populaire en force et les le temps dont
les éducateurs de prévention là on a
plus d'éducateurs de prévention comme on
avait dans les quartiers auparavant
voilà il ya tout plein de mesures qui
sont à prendre pour remettre les jeunes
et qui ment dans le droit chemin mais
surtout pas punir les parents qui
souvent sont démunis et qui ont
justement besoin de la société pour que
leurs enfants soient pris en charge et
se détournent de ce trafic de drogue
avait buté sassone estrosi préconise
aussi un renforcement des pouvoirs des
policiers pour lutter contre ces
troubles du voisinage vous êtes d'accord
avec ça ah oui bien sûr moi je pense
qu'il n'y a pas assez de toutes façons
de beaucoup de quartiers au manque de
policiers le maire écologiste de lyon
d'ailleurs grégory doucet et le
président de la métropole mono bernard
j'étais avec eux il ya quelques mois
nous avons demandé ensemble dans
responsabilité aux ministres darmanin
renforcement des effectifs de police
nationale ce qu'ils ont d'ailleurs
obtenu pour que dans les quartiers où il
n'y a pas assez de police de proximité
et bien au plus avoir à nouveau des
policiers qui sont régulièrement sur le
quartier qui sont identifiés par par les
citoyens et qu'ils puissent faire
utilement ce travail de deux à la fois
de prévention est d'être présent lorsque
il faut effectivement interpellé
merci hiver julien-laferrière d'avoir
répondu ce matin en direct à nos
questions dans la matinale d'arreter
france